[موسيقى]
مساء الخير على حضراتكم في الحلقه دي بنست
انف طرح اسئله حضراتكم على الدكتور جوده
عبد الخالق مساء الخير معال الدكتور مساء
الحريه لي للساده المشاهدين وطبعا في كل
مكان ربنا يخلي حضرتك في سؤال عن الصين
الصين بتعاني ا من حوالي اكث من سنه بشكل
واضح تعافت بسرعه من ازمه كورونا
وده كان مؤشر يعني مثير
للابهر ثم بدات تظهر عليه علامات الاجهاد
الشريد لاسباب يطول شرحها يعني اسباب
كتيره جدا اولا في تقدير حضرتك هل الازمه
الاقتصاديه اللي احد اهم يعني توابعها ضعف
الطلب والتباطؤ في النمو هل دي ازمه عارضه
بتعتقد ام انها ازمه قد تطول واذا طالت
طبعا هتكون اثارها
كبيره يعني خلينا نصور الموضوع ربما
للتبسيط بفكره سياره منطلقه جدا ها اللي
هي الاقتصاد الصيني في هذه الحاله بسرعه
عاليه وانه عندها كان مقومات هذه السرعه
العاليه انه عنده وقود كافي عنده محرك قوي
عنده طريق واضح وممهد كويس طيب لو اختل
واحد من
هذه المقاومات الثلاثه يعني معنى ان
الوقود نفسه
يقل او ان المحرك يص مشكله او ان الطريق
يص في هذه الحاله تتوقع انه هذه الاله
المتحركه تبتدي تواجه بعض المصاعب
فتتباطأ بدايه من 78 تحديدا
مظبوط قايمه على فرضيه انه هناك متسع لا
حدود له لما يمكن ان يستوعبه العالم مما
تنتجه اله الصينيه عظيم وبالتالي زود سرعه
الاقتصاد
ينتج
يعني قدر المستطاع ولن تكون هناك مشكله
تصريف اه ان العالم هيستوي ما
تنتجه اله الانتاج الجباره الس الكلام ده
طبعا كما هو الحال في في ظواهر كثيره جدا
لا يوجد شيء بلا حد انما الفكره طب ما هو
الحد ومتى سنصل اليه اي واحد ده سؤال مهم
في التخطيط الاستراتيجي انك انت الحد ده
ممكن يبقى في افق 10 15 20 سنه ها وايه
اللي بيحكموا ففي هذه الحاله بالنسبه
للصين انه اولا يعني ظهرت عده صينات اخرى
انجاز التعبير بتعمل نفس الشيء بتنتج
وتصرف اصبح في مزاحمه من جانب واحد اثنين
انه
ا على
مستوى
استراتيجي الصراع المنتظر والقائم حاليا
والمتوقع الى سنوات وهو حاكم صراع على
الزعامه الاقتصاديه والسياسيه لعالم بين
الولايات المتحده الزعيم الحالي وبين
الصين باعتبار اهم المرشحين المحتملين ل
فده ابتدى ياثر ايضا على قدره الصين على
تصريف انتاجها باعتبار انه كان اكبر اماكن
التصريف هو الاقتصاد الامريكي بحكم
الحج طبعا عمليا ده جا في مواقف زي ترامب
وقال لك لا لا مش هنعمل الكلام ده هنرجع
الصناعه عندنا انما كله في السياق
الاستراتيجي بتكلم
عليه اذا
ابتد الوقود اللي بيغذي هذه الاله يقل
انه مافيش امكانيه لتصريف الاسواق طب ايه
البديل عشان الاله السم دور السوق الداخلي
التسويق الداخلي داخلي له متطلبات وشبهها
برض بالعوده الى نموذج العربه او السياره
انك انت
عشان يعني بتنقل من سرعه لازم
تنقل معامل التسريع يعني تبط الحركه
وبعدين رجع تزودها تاني لما تاخد المسار
الايه المسار الجديد فده معناه ايه انك
انت
لازم تشوف اليات تصريف الانتاج داخليا في
في
الصين وبالمناسبه يمكن ناس كتير مايعرفوش
انه في اطار تطور الصين السريع
خلال 50 سنه الاخيره من السبعينات حتى
الان او
حصل صحيح نجح الصين
في تخفيض الفقر بنسبه مدهشه جدا ولكن في
نفس الوقت حصل تفاوت في توزيع الدخل
والثروه داخل الصين عالي للغايه هذا
التفاوت في توزيع الثرو والدخل ذكر ما
قلناه على مستوى الاقتصاد الع ابتدا يبقى
يشكل حد لما يمكن
ان نتوقعه من القدره على تصريف الانتاج في
هذه السوق ا عدد كبير من يعني من المحدود
الدخل بلاش نقول الفقراء غير قادرين على
شراء كل ما يتم انت في عندك يعني اعداد
كبيره يعني مئات الملايين ده صحيح ولكن في
في نفس الوقت مساله ليست مساله مجرد عدد
انما القوه الشرائيه المتاحه هذه القوه
محكومه بهيكل
توزيع الكعكه الاقتصاديه سواء في شكل داخل
او في شكل ايه وبناء عليه بناء عليه انه
وان تقديري انه نتوقع
انه انتهى زمن هذا النمو السريع جدا للصين
عندما اصبح جزء من التاريخ وانه احد
المشاكل السياسيه والاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
والثقافيه الكبرى بالنسبه للصين واحداث
النقله من تحريك
الاقتصاد استنادا الى القدره على التصريف
في الخارج الى تحريكه استنادا الى القدره
على التصريف في الداخل اذا حرك بتقول انه
الاقتصاد فعلا الصيني بيعيش ازمه لكن
الازمه دي بتاتي في ظل
يعني يعني نظره او
اعتبارات مش بس اقتصاديه لكن استراتيجيك
يعني جيو ستراتيجيك انه واحد ان هي كانت
بتعتمد ان هي سوف تصدر بلا حدود الى
العالم وفعلا العالم كان متعطش الى
البضائع الصينيه الجيده نسبيا واللي يعني
سهمت فيها دول العالم زي المانيا وامريكا
وغيره وبايدي عامله رخيصه اللي حصل انه في
الفتره الاخيره ظهرت لنا الصين عده ص مش
عارف جمع الصين ايه صينيات صغيرات يعني
مثلا احنا عندنا فيتنام بتصنع بنجلاديش
بتصنع دول الهند بتصنع فبدا هناك
منافسين اصحاب مصانع اخرى بنفس المصنع
الصيني الامر الثاني طبعا لا يخفى على احد
وهو الخوف الامريكي الهائل من الصعود
الصيني ارادوا وقف هذا النمو بوضع ضوابط
وقيود على الصادرات الصينيه العاملين دول
حرموا الصين من فرص كبيره لتصريف انتاجهم
ودلوقتي حرج بتقول ان هم بيحاولوا انه
يتوجهوا الى السوق الداخلي لكن هذه
العمليه تبقى عمليه انتقاليه هتحتاج وقت
وحتى يتم هذا اذا تم بنجاح هيبقى في تباطؤ
صحيح ولكن برضو لان الموضوع في تعقيدات
كثيره ف اشير الى بعدين للموضوع بعد الاول
انه من الممكن في اطار التنافس
الاستراتيجي بين الصين والولا المتحده
واعتقد ان هناك مؤشرات ان هذا حدث بالفعل
ان الصين تزيد من انفاقها
العسكري كويس يبقى في الحاله دي انت مش
محتاج لطلب نهائي في شكل طالب مستهلكين
انما المواريه توجه الانتاج ادوات التدمير
انتظارا للمواجهه المرتقبه مع القطب الاخر
اللي هو الولايات المتحده ويمكن اللي
بيتابع الاحداث في المنطقه بتاع بحر الصين
وطبعا الصراع حول تيوان يدرك هذا الم
انا اتمنى الواحد يبقى عنده وقت يشوف
الاحصاءات طبعا الموضوع مش سهل لانه ما
فيش شفافيه كبيره انما توقعي ان الصين
تكون بدعت بالفعل من فتره تواجه جزء من
الانتاج الداخلي للانفاق الايه العسكري ده
يحيل مشكله نقص الطلب الناتجه عن
انسداد الافق بتاع التصوف الخ الشيء
الثاني انه في اطار الرؤيه الاستراتيجيه
للصين فكره الحزام والطريق وان دي تنطوي
على مجالات
للانفاق ليست بالقليله في مشروعات
استثماريه بالذات في مجال النقل
واللوجستيات وبتصل الى
اماكن تمتد الى افريقيا
و وسط اسيا الى حدود اوروبا من هذه
الزاويه لكن كل ايه هدف يعني يعني تقصد ان
ده يغنيها عن ايه ده
هيعوض نقص الطلب جز من النقص في الطلب
ولكن له حدود لان هذه المشروعات لها افق
في النهايه لما تنتهي يبقى اذا الزياده
انما حاليا بيشكل نوع من قوه الدفع لهذه
الاله المتحركه الى حين فلما ده يستنزف
ولما يحس انه بن قوه عسكريه يبقى عنده
محكوم بالمعضلة
الحرب المرتقبه و خلي بالك هو التاريخ
بيعلمنا بالمناسبه انه زعامه العالم
اقتصاديا دائما تنتقل عبر عقب حرب يعني
اذا حدث في بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه
لما ازيحت بريطانيا وحلت محلها الولايات
المتحده بس الحرب مش بين الطرفين لا لا
الحرب هي بتخلق بيئه حاضنه تسمح بحدوث
التحول من قطب الى قطب اخر نفس الشيء حصل
تاريخيا قبل كده بين بين بريطانيا من
ناحيه وبين هولندا
وبرتغال من ناحيه اخرى قبل الحرب اه اه
يعني والمانيا كمان هو ده
بيذكرني ثوسيس ستراب او مصيده ثوسيس بحاول
افتكر اسم الاستاذ اللي
عملها جرهام حاجه هو استاذ في جامعه
هارفرد وكتب كتاب مهم جدا هل الصين
والولايات المتحده ستن وور لازم يحاربه
فعمل دراسه هو وفريق بحثي الدراسه ديت
اطلق عليها مصيده ثو سيسس وثيو سيسس ده هو
المؤرخ اللي من 1400 سنه سنه ارخ الصراع
ما بين اثينا و سبارتا وكان خلاصه نظريته
ان سبارتا مشكلتها الاساسيه مع اثينا مش
ان اثينا عاوزه تؤذيها مجرد ان هي موجوده
وبتصعب كل الاحوال اي حاجه هتعملها اثينا
اسبارتا ستشعر الخطر فهو رصد حوالي 16
حاله عبر 500 سنه انه قوه مسيطره بتشعر
بالقلق من قوه مهيمنه وان 12 حاله تمت
عمليه الانتقال عن طريق الصراع المسلح
مضبوط واربع حالات فقط منها حاله انتقال
السلطه من بريطانيا الى الولايات المتحده
تمت بدون يعني صراع مباشر لكن طبعا كان في
صراع ادى الى
اضعاف بريطانيا يعني ف بس حضرتك قلت قلت
نقطتين مهمتين يا معال الدكتور انت بتقول
ان ممكن
نتيجه الاعتبارات اللي انت قلتها وجود
اكثر من دوله بتنافس الصين على الانتاج
والقيود اللي بتفردها امريكا وحلفائها
تتوقع ان الصين تذهب الى تعويض نقص الطلب
على منتجاتها بزياده انتاج السلاح بس
العائد ده هيروح لمين يعني السلاح ده يعني
لجيشها يبقى هي كده ما اضافت لنفسها كتير
ولا ده للتصدير يعني لا سلاح اساسا لها
مسبب لان هو الفكره انك انت عايز تخلق ما
انت عندك اله انتاجيه جباره ولابد من
تصريف الانتاج انت ممكن تنتج دبابه او
سياره اه كويس يعني يعني من الناحيه
الفنيه مافيش فرق كبير بالاثنين اه طيب
السياره دي كنت بتصرفها في الولايات
المتحده السوده ماعادش موجود بتعمل ايه
عندك طاقه انتاجيه بتدي توجه الطاقه
الانتاجيه لانتاج الدبابه كويس او مدافع
او ذخيره خ كلها صناعات هندسيه في النهايه
وبالتالي الهدف مش
انه العائد هيعود على مين انما ايجاد
مجال لتوظيف الطاقه الانتاجيه
الهائله في في هذا النطاق النطاق العسكري
بعد ما تقلصت مجالات التصريف الخارجيه دي
نقطه بس اصد في فرق في الاثر كبير السياره
بتادي الى زياده الانتاج ورفاهيه الانسان
لكن الدبابه هتفضل موجوده الى ان تستخدم
بشكل يؤدي لضرر احد الاطراف يعني صح ولكن
في النهايه عشان تنتج الدبابه انت بتوظف ا
عدد والات وبشر واموال وكل هذا الكلام
معناه ايه معناه الاله الانتاجيه بتدور هو
ده التحدي الكبير بالنسبه يعني خلي بالك
اقتصاد بحجم اقتصاد الصين لو بصنا لها من
زاويه
ثانيه عالم الماديات في الطبيعه في في
حاجه اسمها العزم الذاتي ده كيان ضخم جدا
و بينطلب عشان يبتدي يبطا العزم الذاتي
بتاعه هيدفع ها فلازم تعمل حاجه عشان تقلل
من المشكلات التي يمكن ان تنتج
من البط التباطؤ السريع على المخطط على
على على انتاج الصين وحضرتك وضحت لنا برض
اديتنا تفسير سبب اهتمام الصين بالحزام
والطريق انه بيوفر لها متنفس ل تصري في
انتاجها جزيل الشكر معالي الدكتور وان كان
الحديث هطرح اسئله اخرى فيكون لقائنا في
حلقه اخرى باذن الله باذن الله باذن الله
شكرا جزيلا لحضراتكم ونلقاكم في حلقات
جديده مع سلسله حلقات افكار الاستاذ الى
اللقاء